what do you think of the bad engrish in
anime
um well uh you know i know people who
who've been asked to like talk in
english when they're not like
you know that it's the director just
like you should do it yeah they're kind
of like
um well they're like try your best but
you know like you know and obviously the
actors are trying their best yeah yeah
it's like i just feel like it's an
unfortunate situation yeah yeah it's
just kind of like oh
i guess they had to but yeah yeah like a
lot of my friends like ask me how to
pronounce stuff because they're like
i don't know how like you know they
pronounce this sentence and
stuff like that so yeah i think it's
really hard for them to like
you know pronounce something that
they're not used to pronouncing do they
ever worry about how it's perceived by
like foreign fans
ah yeah they do they're like you know i
i tried my best but
it's like i don't think it sounds like
native and then you know
you know feel bad laughing at the
crocodiles
or the lunchtime rush one uh the
crocodile basket yeah go to america
and then oh yeah they go to america they
forgot and everyone's american but
everyone's japanese
like yeah it's it's a trip well i mean
it's like the english and like devilman
crybaby as well right yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah
and i had to i have to do affordable
next to that guy oh really yeah
oh yeah yeah and it's like yeah i mean
like i mean
it's it's it's not a no one wins yeah
well yeah no one wins
i mean like his english was probably the
most decent out of like all the other
actors but like
yeah i had the exact same thing like
during break like all the actors were
coming up to me being like how do you
pronounce this
how do i make this sound as fluent and
like naturally
speaking as possible and i'm just like
dude you're asking the wrong person this
is set in new york
i'm not even doing the acting correctly
why are you asking me like i'm
struggling to say the letter r
i'm walking here just say that that's
what everyone says that's the meme
just give them a copy of like every man
scorsese